and the Democrats as I said seem to have
no interest in working with President
Trump on cultural issues or anything for
that matter but is that good politics
well not according to a poll I mentioned
just a short while ago this new private
poll conducted from the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee as
reported by Axios they found that
Democrats running in these swing
districts quote must express a
willingness to work for the President as
I said well joining me now for reaction
is Shelby Steele a senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution dr. Steele great to
see you how are you I'm good I'm good
good to be here
does that surprise you that there seems
to be a unwillingness on the part of
Democrats even on issues where the
president has moved let's say on moving
on that issue of the daca kids from
800,000 kids who would have gotten
amnesty dr. Steele to 1.8 million who
would have received amnesty under the
Trump proposal but the Democrats in the
end as I predicted said not going to do
it that's right that's right there is
the source of their power and on the the
American Left I think has a lot to do
with supporting policies that win them a
kind of innocence in the culture that
put them on the side of the good that
show them to be redeeming the nation
from its ugly racist sexist so forth
past and and so that's what they're
looking for in the bills like this and
then in much of what they're they pursue
today because the other side of that is
that America has morally grown in the
last 50 years it is not the racist
society that I grew up in for example
today it is you can say that the
oppression of minorities is over with
it's it's simply no longer a systemic
part of our lives we can do what we want
well this pretty much pulls the rug out
from under liberalism they have no other
mandate than to rectify history and
rectify the past
and so they they're a bit exhausted at
this point they don't know what to do
next
well this Stephan Clark funeral that I
mentioned just a few minutes ago al
sharpton flies in he gets up and he
speaks at the funeral people are very
impassioned he says I flew here 3,000
miles only for this family and to keep
this going and we have a soundbite let's
watch White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders to say this is a
local issue is a main reason that many
of us said no matter what we'll be here
this is not a local issue it's a
national problem it's a national problem
now we'll see what the necks of this
case ultimately show but whether it was
Trayvon Martin or Michael Brown or
Freddie gray each horrible incident
ended up becoming 8 no racial flashpoint
regardless of what the ultimate facts
determined dr. Steele well the the the
flashpoint if we're going to have a
flashpoint should be mr. Sharpton should
fly to Chicago where in 2016 760 to
young black largely boys shot by other
black boys committed that many murders
in one year where was Reverend Sharpton
then again liberalism goes after excuse
me examples of victimization what's
what's amazing about mr. Sharpton he has
a passion for Vic black victimization he
loves it he celebrates it he won't let
anybody else anybody escape it because
victimization is his only source of
power he has nothing else to offer
nothing to say about the economy
immigration whatever nor do most people
on the Left have much to say about those
issues but they can sure call people
racist they can sure take positions that
give them this sort of aura of innocence
from the
American but I'm not a racist I'm an
innocent good-hearted America and we're
going to go and we're gonna have
diversity and inclusion and and and so
forth while they actually ignore the
real problems if you got 762 boys being
shot on the south side of Chicago in one
year that suggests a profound almost
unheard-of level of human pathology in
particularly in the Western world well
what do they have we will believe them
again when they begin to have something
meaningful to say about that
circumstance and dr. Steele we've talked
about this before on radio and you're so
insightful on what's happened to the
actual debate I mean I saw this going
all the way back to college where
there's an attempt to shut down debate
if someone actually raises a point about
you know what happens when our fighting
forces are become social experimentation
places then your anti-trans or your anti
this or anti that instead of having a
conversation okay what works best for
the military or what works best for our
borders your anti-immigrant so the left
does not want a discussion they want to
impose their will on others and if you
do not bow down to them they want to try
to demonize you or you know isolate the
Solomons detect the insky tactics that
are so patently obvious at this point
that's that's absolutely right they they
really want they want to shame you and
that's really what they are about again
they have no other raison d'etre
other than this sort of again
identification with innocence and moral
superiority and so forth the one thing
that liberalism hates the most
which conservatism by the way tends to
represent is pragmatism how do we in the
nuts and bolts of it how do we fix the
problem like the the family breakdown we
see across the black America today I
don't what do we do there pragmatically
down on the ground that can actually
move move us into the modern world now
that we as blacks we enjoy this level of
freedom what's going to take
meet help us meet that challenge nothing
to say they want to take us back to the
old world he wants to fly to Sacramento
stand before the coffin of another black
kid and and basically identified that
event with slavery and segregation and
so forth and such and and
show himself to be humanely concerned
with all of this when of course he never
appears in in Chicago or Baltimore or
st. Louis or Detroit it is it's a
heartbreaker and it but it is utterly
predictable and it to a lot of people
it's utterly depressing but your
insights are amazing I do a whole hour
with you thank you so much for coming on
tonight we really really appreciate it